[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 18 février
l'heure n'est pas au relâchement
qu'ovide oblige mais surtout variant
oblige une deuxième vague qui se
prolonge ou tout comme la durée
d'isolement des patients testés positifs
elle passe de 7 à 10 jours à partir de
lundi
olivier verront le martèlent les
prochaines semaines seront clés alors
que 36% des tests positifs sont
aujourd'hui britannique la campagne de
vaccination elle devrait encore
accélérer et son rire aux 65 74 entre
fin mars et fin avril
le coc vide à l'échelle planétaire la
pandémie a fait au moins 2,43 millions
de morts depuis fin décembre 2019 alors
que des pays affrontent leur 2ème 3ème
4ème vague avec des restrictions qui
dure depuis maintenant des mois
illustration ce soir au royaume uni ou
15 millions de personnes ont déjà été
vaccinées relais stevenson présentera
son plan de déconfinement le 22 février
comment sauver l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien la question est au coeur de la
réunion entre européens et américains
les chefs de la diplomatie française
britannique et allemand s'entretiennent
toi aujourd'hui avec les états unis
alors que téhéran prévoit de restreindre
l'activité d'inspecteurs de l'aiea ses
installations nucléaires
si washington ne lève pas de ces
sanctions imposées depuis 2000 18 ans
[Musique]
conférence de presse tout à l'heure
d'olive y verront sur la situation
sanitaire la partie n'est pas encore
gagnée les prochaines semaines seront
décisives notamment en raison de la
propagation des variants pour plus de
précisions nous retrouvons tout de suite
notre reporter david khalifa en direct
de l'avenue de ségur
bonsoir d'avis khalifa la traditionnelle
conférence de presse s'est achevé il y à
peu que peut-on en retenir
et bien sûr le même ton que gabriel
attal hier ollier verreault n'a pas fait
de grande annonce mais un point sur
l'épidémie le ministre de la santé a une
nouvelle fois a mis en garde les
français contre tout relâchement les
chiffres restent stables en concernant
le coville 19 et le gouvernement veut
garder son cap jusqu'à la fin des
vacances scolaires et poursuivre sa
gestion de la crise sanitaire en
maintenant notamment le couvre-feu
national à 18h et coûtait rien ne serait
pire que de lever les contraintes certes
lourde mais ô combien nécessaire au
mauvais moment
trop tôt relâcher notre vigilance
maintenant c'est courir le risque de
contraintes plus fortes dans un avenir
proche
courir le risque d'avoir tenu ensemble
si longtemps enfin nous devons encore
tenir ensemble faire reculer vraiment le
virus sortir de la zone de danger
nous l'avons fait déjà en mai dernier
nous en connaissons le chemin
nos efforts ont déjà payé mais la partie
n'est pas encore gagnée
enfin et je vous en parle semaine après
semaine le risque lié à la diffusion
croissante des variants de l'aco vide en
france et dans le monde n'est pas encore
maîtrisée loin de là et il pose un
certain nombre de questions
vous l'avez dire l'inquiétude se porte
désormais à sur l'évolution des variants
britanniques et un sud africain et
brésilien o dia verront était d'ailleurs
accompagné d'une épidémiologiste lors de
cette conférence de presse pour
justement exposés à des projections où
elle estime une flambée de l'épidémie
fin mars
alors pour l'instant le gouvernement
préfère tempérer mais elle prend des
mesures avec notamment le rallongement
de l' isolement qui passe de 7 à 10
jours en cas de contamination au commis
19 écouter
nous allons un cran plus loin certaines
études scientifiques évoquent la
possibilité que les variants puisse être
responsable d'une durée de contagiosité
plus importante que celle du co vide 19
classique qui circulent et jusqu alors
dans le pays
sans attendre la confirmation et dans la
mesure où la part de variants dans les
contaminations est devenu élevé j'ai
décidé que la durée de l'isolément de
tous les patients dont un test
diagnostique est positif passera à
compter de lundi de sept à dix jours
elle restera en revanche de 7 jours pour
les cas contacts très david l'attention
spitalier reste importante et c'est sur
ce point que l'exécutif s'inquiète
également oui alors on marche sur des
oeufs et on évalue la situation au jour
le jour voilà comment on peut résumer la
gestion de crise du gouvernement
malgré une légère décrue dans les
hôpitaux ça reste très compliquée
plusieurs un département font notamment
face à une circulation plus forte du
courant navires us comme dans le nord le
sud est et l'est de la france ce qui
fait craindre une satire à une
saturation dans les établissements de
santé et pour pallier cette tension la
direction générale de la santé invite
les hôpitaux à se réorganiser en
augmentant la capacité en termes de lits
de réanimation et de soins intensifs
autre question sur laquelle le
gouvernement va devoir se pencher
l'allègement des restrictions alors on
l'a compris pour l'instant ce n'est pas
possible
mais si la situation venait à
s'améliorer le gouvernement devra faire
face aux demandes d'allègement de ces
mesures dans les prochaines semaines 1
concernant notamment la réouverture des
lieux publics comme les restaurants ou
bien encore les musées merci david
khalifa est pas un mot donc justement
vous lisiez david ans sur ces fameux
restaurant et les lieux de loisirs il
reste fermé pour le moment le
gouvernement qui travaillerait sur la
mise en place d'un quad core à la q aide
qu air pardon code à l'entrée des
restaurants des bars et des salles de
sport on en parle avec à nos invités
et nous sommes avec patrick malvaes
président du syndicat national des
discothèques et lieux de loisirs
stéphane manigold restaurateurs porte
parole du mouvement restons ouverts
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
alors olivier verront là dit il ne
serait pas responsable de rouvrir les
lieux fermés pas le moment de relâcher
nos efforts donc en clair pour vous ça
veut dire toujours pas de date de
réouverture vous désespérez s'était fait
de manigold plus les jours passent plus
les semaines passent et plus elles se
ressemblent et la sai on entend à
nouveau le même discours un pas relâcher
les efforts mais en attendant on est
fermée donc des efforts le fait et on
les fait au maximum et on voit que le
les hospitalisations sont toujours là on
a essayé de mettre en place des
protocoles sanitaires de proposer des
protocoles sanitaires à renforcer de
façon à ce qu'on puisse rouvrir pas de
sujet je crois que olivier ferrand est
complètement fermée à cette situation
alors ne caricaturons pas non plus tout
gouvernement
il ya des personnes qui sont sortis
vainqueurs aisés à bruno le maire et qui
sont à nos côtés
on essaye de leur faire des propositions
pour ouvrir notamment de terrasses comme
à new york
même s'il fait froid c'est un variable
qui est compliqué tout le monde n'a pas
des terrasses tous les restaurateurs
n'ont pas il ya encore des réglages à
faire sur le fond de solidarité qui met
beaucoup de temps à arriver
voyez tous et tous ces points là pour
nous sont essentiels parce que c'est la
survie et c'est de pouvoir demain rester
ouverts restons ouverts d'esprit reste
ouvert dans le dialogue reste en débat
mais la laisse pas se ressembler on voit
pas du tunnel soyons clairs alors
patrick malvaes vous vous représentez
les discothèques alors là il a carrément
même pas un mot on a vraiment le
sentiment que ce seront les dernières à
ouvrir
comment vous prenez justement ce silence
c'est quelque chose que vous comprenez
ou au contraire nous imaginez vous que
c'est un manque de respect d'ici là
c'est absolument inquiétant le mot
discothèque c'est soit un nouveau mot
soit un mot qu'on élude pendant tous les
cas c'est pas très satisfaisant et c'est
très très dommage
faire des efforts en ce qui concerne des
discothèques je vois pas ce que l'on
peut faire en plus les discothèques sont
fermées ça fait treize mois
c'est la première profession qui était
fermée de façon continue jeudi bis de
façon continue depuis 13 mois car vous
imaginez que quand on voit qu'on oublie
un secteur qui souffre à ce point là qui
se trouvent dans cette position là c'est
parfaitement inacceptable qu'on ait été
oubliée bon on est oubliés au niveau des
discours officiels
c'est vrai que c'est pas toujours
vendeur sauf peut être quand on veut en
parler de mauvaise façon
mais
sur le plan des aides matérielles nous
avons par le biais du fonds de
solidarité une assistance que je
qualifierais de minimal qui a été
améliorée ces derniers mois et nous
essayons de se vivre avec ça c'était des
l'élu d'un gros problème qui est le
problème la rémunération des exploitants
quand vous avez une exploitation
commerciale
c'est certes un moyen de faire de
l'argent et les collecter la tva et des
taxes pour l'état de payer son personnel
mais les dirigeants ne sont pas pris en
charge par le chômage et les dirigeants
se retrouvent sans salaire depuis 13
mois or ce sont les dirigeants de ces
établissements qui ont investi leur
propre argent comme gage de leur bien
quand tout mis dans la balance pour
créer leur établissement et aujourd'hui
c'est trop perdre ils peuvent avoir
perdu leur fonds de commerce et en même
temps ils n'ont pas d'argent pour
pouvoir continuer à payer les dettes qui
sont les leurs dons qui vont devoir
exécuter les garanties qu'ils ont
données soient leurs maisons soient
leurs biens personnels des eaux ils ont
perdu leur faut il risque de perdre
hormis le personnel voilà où en est la
situation pour d'aujourd'hui c'est tout
à fait critique patrick malvaes vous
parlez on reviendra sur stéphane
manigold évidemment tout à l'heure dont
vous parlez de survie est ce qu on a une
idée du nombre de discothèques qui ont
fermé en france parce qu'on imagine que
la situation comme vous dit doit être
vraiment critique pour beaucoup d'entre
elles
vous savez d'une gradation dans
l'horreur vous avez malheureusement
comme partout vous avez plus d'une
centaine d'établissements qui ont fait
un dépôt de bilan c'est à dire que les
tribunaux de commerce ont décidé de les
fermer
ces établissements sont fermés on n'en
parle plus ces 100 à 120 établissements
vous avez derrière une procédure qui
entre les deux procédures de sauvegarde
et procédure de règlement judiciaire
on a désigné un administrateur et est là
ou si vous avez 100 150 établissements
qui sont là dans cette situation un peu
pénible pourquoi ils sont venus dans
cette situation c'est parce qu'ils ont
préféré se mettre dans des situations de
sauvegarde parce qu'ils ont des
bailleurs est propriétaire des murs de
leurs établissements qui continuent à
vouloir percevoir leurs loyers
commerciaux au même niveau que ce qui
l'était quand on fonctionne et donc
comme les établissements ne fonctionne
plus quand ils ont des loyers
commerciaux de vaincre
quarante mille euros c'est sûrement pas
pour donner uniquement aux bailleurs aux
propriétaires des murs qui se fait
beaucoup d'argent là-dessus avec un
fonds de commerce qui peut plus être
exploitée pour la destination pour
laquelle ils étaient loués et puis vous
avez une troisième donc ils sont
grossières de sauvegarde ca moyen
d'échapper à ce qui est ainsi très
particulier parce que le gouvernement
n'a pas pris là toutes les mesures qu'il
fallait envers les bailleurs et il faut
bien le dire comme ça donc on se trouve
obligé de se mettre à ces procédures de
sauvegarde où on se trouve obligée
d'aller devant les tribunaux
actuellement a déclaré annie quelques
instants ce très très importante et de
principe devant les tribunaux c'est
quand même assez rentable de voir aussi
ses patrons sur ce front là et vous avez
le troisième niveau de gradation endroit
ce sont des gens qui eux mêmes prenantes
et la situation que rien ne bouge et ont
décidé de fermer leur établissement
alors la plupart d'entre eux étaient des
très petits établissements au début vous
aviez à peu près 120 130 autour d'eux en
1950 parce que vous avez une vingtaine
d'établissements moyens au plus haut qui
ont rejoint les hanter qui ont décidé de
fermer ses e même qui volontairement
décidé de fermer et vous trouvez une
bibliothèque qui sont en vente sur des
sites sociaux actuellement je voudrais
vous faire écouter vitoria colza en
directrice de recherche à l'inserm elle
était aujourd'hui aux côtés d'olivier
verrons lors de ce point hebdomadaire
écouter ce qu'elle vit sur le couvre-feu
ce qu'on a pu voir sinon selon ces
analyses en tenant compte de la présence
nous varions britannique sur un
territoire en france au début de l'année
est issu des estimations de la première
enquête flèche que ses coureurs peu
anticipée a eu un impact considérable
sur la sur les reculs de la souche
historique ici j'appelle la souche
historique que les virus sur scorff deux
qui étaient en circulation de même dans
l'année 20 ans avant l'arrivée des
variances sur le territoire français en
gros si on avait que c'est vers ces
souches
il a suffi historique on serait capable
aujourd'hui d'avoir un recul dé
l'épidémie dans les temps grâce à ces
couvre feu à 18h graphiques à l'appui
stéphane manute bol quand vous voyez ces
graphiques et des explications de madame
polizia setaf est implacable ça vous
inquiète tout de même qu'est ce que
vous répondez soit le ministre houle en
tout cas le ministère de la santé ne va
pas assez loin dans la transparence des
explications et datant de résister de la
colline
parce qu'il y a il faut être clair des
débats profonds sur le fait que l'on
vive à côté non pas derrière ni de vent
mais à côté de ce virus et que l'on vive
normalement
soit ils ne disent pas réellement ce
qu'il en est c'est à dire que au fond il
ya une dangerosité bien plus importante
et raison pour laquelle on pénalise
globalement 99% de la population
française mais du reste je pas jeter la
pierre à la france dans le monde entier
c'est comme ça donc soit on nous dit pas
réellement quelles sont les conséquences
les troubles et les risques qu'il y a
lié à cette maladie au delà des décès
que l'on voit et que l'on peut constater
qu'ici qu'on peut que déplorer ces
soixante quinze mille en france mais il
y a certainement des déjà un sens
neurologiques auquel on nous parle pas
et ça ça créé une fracture au fond avec
les français et les françaises sur cette
incompréhension ou alors tout simplement
on est on est dans le virus tel qu'on le
décrit et on comprend pas
fondamentalement pourquoi on priverait
autant de personnes de fermer mais
restons deux secondes sur sur l'économie
on en parlait tout à l'heure les
bailleurs il ne joue absolument pas le
jeu ce sont les protégés de cette crise
sanitaire
pour la simple et bonne raison c'est
qu'ils n'ont absolument pas joué le jeu
lorsque le gouvernement met en place des
dispositifs notamment de réductions
d'impôts sur les traits déployés qui ont
été proposées ils n'ont pas joué le jeu
et je ne vois pas pourquoi une
entreprise comme des discothèques comme
des théâtres comme des commerçants des
artisans des agriculteurs etc devraient
faire dès qu'on appelle prêts garantis
par l'état pour subvenir à des besoins
primaires de trésorerie et pourquoi ces
grands fonds
ces bailleurs et ses ébats et ferait pas
comme nous ils font appel à un prêt
garanti par l'état qui leur permettent
est bien de faire face à leurs frais ils
font des reports bancaire comme nous
avons fait jusqu'à 12 mois
ils font des rebords bancaire si l'on
sait on nous c'est tout le temps tout le
temps la pauvre petite mamie et c'est
déplorable et je peux comprendre qu'elle
a besoin
de cette pension pour vivre mais souvent
nous la gîte
mais moi je pense aussi à la mamie qui a
besoin de ça et qui aujourd'hui un local
vide et qui demain ne retrouvera pas un
locataire lorsque vous parlez des 120
discothèque qui ont fermé je peux vous
dire que celui qui est le bailleur
derrière il n'est pas prêt de trouver un
locataire
donc je crois qu'à un moment les
bailleurs doivent faire des efforts
substantiels comme nous l'avons fait
maintenant depuis plus d'un an
notre outil de travail de tutti qui nous
permet de générer du du résultat pour
pouvoir les payer il n'est pas là et
rappelons tout de même que la cour
d'appel de paris s'est positionné le 9
décembre sur la force majeure en
indiquant que au fond les bailleurs à la
force majeure s applique c'est à dire
que les contrats se sont suspendus
vous voyez bien que il y a une espèce
encore deux de tension qui se rajoute au
stress à ce virus qui se propage au
manque de lisibilité
mes amis de la discothèque j'en parle
même pas je crois que le quand leur
slogan était de dire la nuit d'avant le
jour les pauvres ils ont jamais été
aussi aussi juste dans leurs slogans
mais aussi loin d'une dune d'une réalité
et quant à la profession tous les non
essentiels qui sont aujourd'hui fermées
n'est pas prêt de voir le jour
mais quand on nous dise clairement ce
sera joint ce sera septembre et au moins
on sera d'ap
mais là toutes les semaines écoutez le
mini la centaine pour nous a expliqué
que les semaines vont être décisives
mais ça fait d'un 52 semaines maintenant
quand on nous explique que les semaines
vont être décisifs donc voyons mon
travail quand même aller à des petits
projets notamment le qr code inclus du
mal à prononcer tout à l'heure à scanner
avant d'entrer
notamment dans des restaurants à stephen
mayne nicholls mais pourquoi pas a tenté
hier
oui pourquoi pas aussi des discothèques
on va vous laisser le mot de la fin mai
mais rapidement tous les deux s'il vous
plaît pour vous laisser parler l'un et
l'autre c'est une bonne idée on va dans
le bon sens tout de même patrick malvaes
avec voilà ce genre de l'initiative de
deux 2 sp du problème pour lui c'est
l'aspect des libertés publiques
qu'en est-il de cela je comprends quand
un exceptionnel il peut y avoir des
mesures exceptionnelles et qui payera
des entorses je rentrerai pas dans le
débat
la deuxième chose c'est que le qr code
est parfaitement incompatible avec ce
qu'on appelle les protocoles
c'est à des protocoles sont mis en place
on peut utiliser ou faire fonctionner
des établissements et des commerces
à condition qu'ils aient un ensemble de
mesures qui sont prises et dans ces
mesures le qr code entre pour une partie
mais il ya d'autres mesures
le problème bien pour les discothèques
c'est que nenni les discothèques ne peut
pas fonctionner avec un protocole qui
prévoit une jauge réduite
nous sommes un modèle économique où on
travaille à flux tendus ou 6 et demain
jeudi vous devez avoir à moitié de votre
clientèle bas il vaut mieux qu'on ne
prend pas c'est tout à fait clair parce
que le la recette ne sera pas au rendez
vous on aura des charges plus
importantes et on perdra plus d'argent
que d'être fermé donc fonctionné pour ne
pas pouvoir fonctionner dans des
conditions normales c'est impossible il
ya une deuxième chose qui est importante
c'est que la discothèque c'est un lieu
très particulier
vous y allez pour deux ou trois heures
et la fonction même de ce dieu c'est la
rencontre et d échange et le couvent it
s'adresse précisément à sa ration dire
aux discothèques
vous ne pouvez plus d'un c'est vous le
pouvez pu rencontrer l'autre vous devez
avoir des masses etc
y a personne tu iras dans ces lieux là
donc c'est même pas la peine de mettre
en place un protocole donc le qr code
pour nous est une discussion tout à fait
secondaire qu'est-ce que ça puisse
servir pour certains commerces pour
certaines fonctions et où peut-être dans
le cas d'un ensemble global au niveau
des discothèques
il est hors de question que l'on réouvre
en mode dégradé si vous permettez
l'expression
et ça n'a rien de péjoratif pour mes
collègues restaurateurs meiway puisque
ggg suis moi même mais
le ch est le cuir toit ne peut pas être
une solution pour stéphane manuel très
rapidement s'il vous plaît ce qu'on
arrive vraiment au bout du débat vous
êtes un petit peu long tous les deux à
chaque fois mais c'est pas grave c'est
intéressant mais vite s'il vous plaît
sur la conclusion de qr codes la bonne
piste
le qr code et emma l'expliqué temps par
le gouvernement est mal compris par tout
le monde
le qr code c'est quoi lorsque nous
étions vert avec un protocole sanitaire
en ce sens et nous devions de toute
façon remplir ce qu'on appelait un
carnet où on enregistrait les noms des
personnes de façon à ce qu'on puisse
nous les alerter c'est un rôle
évidemment qui nous incombe pas nous
n'avons pas de pouvoir de police et
encore moins pouvoir de santé et bien le
qr code permet en fait d'enlever ce
fameux carnets d'enregistrement des gens
qui venaient dans nos établissements
mais il le remplace simplement
donc on parle de liberté oui liberté oui
liberté pour tous évidemment mais on
peut pas considérer de façon collective
que la punition elle est collective ou
rien ça c'est pas possible
celles et ceux qui veulent pas
participer à sabha malheureusement le
confinement il est là et puis on le voit
en autriche c'est en en train de
regarder le modèle autrichien puisqu'ils
ont appliqué ce cette espèce de 2,2
fonctionnement pour autant les restants
ne sont pas ouverts donc si c'est pour
nous mettre des règles
au fond les non essentiel en reste fermé
ça ne fonctionne pas si c'est pour qu'on
puisse les ouvrir et que les gens qui
sont non porteurs du virus puissent
pouvoir circuler et profiter de la
liberté et les autres se protéger ceux
qui sont atteints de l'aco ville
évidemment il faut être favorable ne
faut pas être manichéen faut être précis
merci en tout cas tous les deux stéphane
manigold et patrick malvaes bon courage
à vous merci et les festivals musicaux
ne pourront pas dépasser la jauge de
5000 spectateurs assis cet été à
décision est tombée ce soir à l'issue
d'une rencontre entre la ministre de la
culture roselyne bachelot et les
professionnels du secteur le
gouvernement se fait avec un tel
dispositif maintenir à tout prix la
distanciation social mais j'ai vu grand
festival français réagit je cite nous
nous allons nous adapter et pour revenir
notamment sur les annonces de roselyne
bachelot nous sommes avec alexis poulain
éditorialistes
ça s'est vu
pour ce soir et alexis poulain merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
quelques annonces donc pour la culture
mais encore beaucoup d'incertitudes a
énormément d'incertitudes peu de
questions ont finalement trouvé leurs
réponses dans la bouche de la ministre
roselyne bachelot qui a évité un les
questions qui fâchent sur l'année
blanche prolongé pour les intermittents
du spectacle il faut rappeler que ceux
là ont quasiment diviser leurs revenus
par deux puisqu'ils n'y a pas de cachet
et que l'année blanche permet simplement
de garder le statut mais ça va être
extrêmement difficile pour beaucoup
d'entre eux de renouveler ce statut et
surtout de retrouver des revenus à
hauteur de ce qu'il était et puis cette
déclaration des festivals de boue qui
serait finalement à 6 a pas plus de 5000
avec les gestes barrières bien entendu
pour beaucoup de festivals évidemment si
vous connaissez un peu la géographie des
festivals ça va être très difficile
festival de musiques amplifiées de
musique
par exemple le festival rock ou de métal
etc ou là on va trouver des gens qui
vont avoir sans doute du mal d'écouter
ce genre de musique assise c'est un peu
même presque une torture alors ça marche
pour les festivals de jazz de musique
classique peut-être évidemment pour les
festivals de musiques amplifiées comme
on l'appelle rue de valois
ça va être beaucoup plus compliqué même
si les vieilles charrues ont dit vouloir
jouer le jeu parce qu'il faut que
effectivement la musique résonne et que
tous les moyens seront bons pour tenir
et faire que les groupes puissent se
produire et jouer mais l'ambiance risque
d'être certainement pas au rendez vous
et c'est un peu compliqué et puis pas de
réponse bien entendu pour le monde de la
nuit qui reste la sinistre est pour
longtemps visiblement pour les
discothèques boîtes de nuit et autres
événements donc ça reste une rencontre
finalement où personne ne se parlait
réellement ou tâter un peu la
température avec beaucoup d'incertitudes
puisque les variants sont là et olivier
derand le disais tout à l'heure ses
variantes ne sais pas comment ça va
évoluer
compte tenu de la contagiosité alors ça
va sans doute augmenter donc un point
mensuel est prévue avec les acteurs du
secteur de la culture
mais ceux-là sont quand même extrêmement
frustré parce que il ne reste que très
peu de temps avant les festivals d'été
et certains ont préféré jeter l'épongé
le cas de solidays c'est le cas aussi
d'autres festivals qui ne vont pas
atteindre l'équilibré qui préfèrent
éviter une annulation de dernière minute
dans le domaine de la culture alexis
l'exécutif qui doit subir on l'a
constaté cette semaine une pression de
plus en plus forte dans des régions et
des mères qui veulent agir en autonomie
oui clairement parce que
il faut rappeler le poids économique de
la culture c'est 3% du pib c'est
plusieurs milliards qui sont en jeu des
millions d'emplois bien plus d'ailleurs
que l'industrie automobile par exemple
et pour certaines régions les festivals
d'été et bien c'est vital à la fois pour
le tourisme mais aussi pour l'économie
locale l'économie régionale c'est le cas
des vielles charrues en l'occurrence qui
a marqué le l'empreinte culturelle dans
le territoire mais aussi qui a fait de
cette région un pôle d'attractivité
grâce à la culture
c'est le cas pour beaucoup d'autres
festivals d'autres rendez vous
artistique et c'est vrai que la pression
monte du haut niveau des mers parce que
ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi on ne
peut pas gérer au niveau local et
surtout ans avec des festivals de plein
air encore une fois on n'est pas dans
des lieux clos si on respecte les gestes
barrière jusqu'à présent il n'y a pas eu
de preuve avérée que les lieux culturels
étaient des lieux de contamination
accéléré de clusters accéléré donc ça
commence évidemment à énerver beaucoup
les élus locaux qui attendent beaucoup
de ces festivals pour relancer le
tourisme et relancer l'économie
en espérant bien sûr que d'ici l'été le
virus aura bien diminué avec à la fois
la campagne de vaccination d'un côté
certaines certains traitements aussi
qu'ils commencent à voir le jour à se
diffuser et puis le fait que le virus
saisonnier voilà pour sortir du tunnel
des pistes que le gouvernement est en
train d'explorer les qr codes
on en a parlé dans le débat mais aussi
les passeports vaccinaux dans les tuyaux
pour pouvoir accéder aux lieux publics
plutôt de bonnes pistes de bonnes pistes
oui non on
l'idée c'est de chercher des solutions
et est à la fois la carotte et le bâton
le bâton le connaissent et le couvre-feu
à 18h les amende de 135 euros
la carotte c'est à dire vous allez
pouvoir sortir de chez vous retrouver
une vie normale à partir du moment où
vous aurez un test positif
ou un passeport vaccinale je vois pas
comment on pourrait mettre en place ce
passeport vaccinale dans les temps c'est
à mon avis une très mauvaise idée parce
que le vaccin jusqu'à preuve du
contraire n'empêche pas la propagation
de l'épidémie il permet simplement
personnellement d'avoir une forme
moindre et d'éviter une hospitalisation
et ça dépend encore en fonction des
variants donc quelle est l'utilité d'un
passeport vaccinale
elle est à mon avis extrêmement limité
néanmoins c'est ce que veulent beaucoup
à la fois l'om est ce qui pousse cette
idée avec un passeport numérique mais
aussi certains pays comme le danemark
comme la grèce qui la grèce qui vit
beaucoup sur le tourisme qui veut
attirer des touristes dès que possible
où les compagnies aériennes pour le qr
code
alors là c'est encore pire c'est
extrêmement intrusif l'idée c'est de
vraiment traquer tout le monde c'est
déjà le cas avec un téléphone portable
ont peu à peu près voir tout ce que vous
faites dans une journée
mais là ce serait officielle dès que
vous allez dans un restaurant dans un
bar ou ailleurs vous seriez flashé pour
savoir où est ce que vous êtes allés
avec l'idée bien sûr de d'avancer encore
davantage dans la connaissance de la
smart city où vont les gens entendent
kovy d'après le kof vide dès qu'on
commence avec ce genre de mesure de
traçage on ne sait pas quand elle
s'arrête je crois qu'il est temps de
lancer l' alerte sur la lente glissade
qui s'accélère de la société de
surveillance qui n'a aucun rôle à jouer
dans le traitement de cette épidémie
puisqu'en fait ça fonctionne simplement
quand on peut contrôler le taux de
diffusion du virus
et là c'est utile évidemment d'avoir une
appli de tracking quand on en est à plus
de 20000 test positif par jour l'appli
tracking n'a plus aucune raison d'être
parce que on a lâché la rampe finalement
on est incapable de continuer de traquer
les gens de leur demander de se mettre à
la maison etc
même si c'est ce qu'ils essayent de
faire le gouvernement mais tout est
encore une fois avec beaucoup de retard
donc à part imposé encore une mesure
liberticide aux français je vois pas
l'intérêt de ce passeport vaccinale
certainement pas et alors du qr codes
encore moins mais si c'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour vers les bars tout le monde
le fera évidemment puisque les gens
veulent retourner dans les restaurants
et dans les bars et que les
propriétaires de ces dieux les gens qui
y travaillent sous être rapidement
retourner au travail
merci alexis poulain rester avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons de
la pandémie avec
elles m'ont bien si le feu n'est pas
éteint comme le précise oms le nombre de
nouveaux cas dans le monde a reculé de
16% sur une semaine et puis nous
reviendrons sur les corps deviennent les
chefs de la diplomatie française
britannique et allemand tz entretiennent
aujourd'hui avec les états unis pour
tenter de le sauver
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes
le son est là mon les actes et j'ai trop
de dépenses trop d'état je pense en tout
cas qu'il ya trop de bureaucratie c'est
à dire un état inefficace tout ça a été
financée essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productive
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue à emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre
20h30 heure française début de la
campagne de vaccination venezuela à
l'aide du bac 100 rue spoutnik v au
total 10 millions de doses ont été
commandées par caracas à la russie le
personnel de santé les députés les
membres de la police et de l'armée
bénéficieront des premières injections
le président mes droits confirmé que lui
et son épouse se feront injecté le sérum
d'ici peu on écoute et bien s'il y avait
moi on se fera vacciner avec le vaccin
sportive et dès que nous le pourrons
selon les priorités nous déciderons du
moment nous feront vacciner tous les
deux et bien sûr nous le ferons en
raison de la force scientifique de ce
vaccin
je crois que scout nick v jusqu'à
présent le plus avancé le meilleur
vaccin au monde
je n'ai aucun doute le venezuela mais
aussi l'argentine le mexique l'algérie
ou encore la hongrie de plus en plus de
pays ont recours à soutenir et dimitri
peskov porte-parole du kremlin sont à
féliciter
quant à la demande pour le vaccin russes
à l'étranger
elle est effectivement forte elle est si
forte qu'elle dépasse largement les
capacités de production
à cette fin un travail intense est en
cours pour lancer dans les prochains
jours la production du vaccin russe dans
un certain nombre de pays étrangers
sa fabrication dans différents pays
étrangers couvrira les besoins des états
étrangers alors que la production
intérieure couvrira les besoins du
marché intérieur
je le répète une fois de plus le marché
intérieur et la santé des citoyens
russes constituent une priorité absolue
le futur c'est la pandémie a fait au
moins 2 43 millions de morts dans le
monde depuis fin décembre 2019 mais
lueur d'espoir le nombre de nouveaux cas
a reculé de 16% sur une semaine selon l'
oms
au royaume uni le confinement porte ses
fruits mais les mesures aux frontières
ont été renforcés en raison de la menace
des variants pour les simpson exposera
son plan de déconfinement le 22 février
le premier ministre qui déclare qu'il
sera prudent mais irréversible et la
campagne se poursuit à bâtons rompus
plus de quinze millions de britanniques
déjà vaccinées
et pour revenir sur la situation
sanitaire au royaume uni nous sommes en
direct depuis et ses terres avec bharat
bank kenya c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir à baratte
appelant le kenya merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france baisse du nombre
de contaminations
enfin les effets du confinement des
efforts consentis par les britanniques
et de la vaccination de masse selon vous
les deux combinés non à faut être très
clair c'est nombre de cas en réduction
c'est surtout dû aux restrictions
lorsque des restrictions sont mises en
place que les gens ne vivent pas leur
vie ordinaire alors le nombre
d'infections baisse nous immuniser que
les populations les plus vulnérables les
personnes les plus âgées
la baisse du nombre de cartons plusieurs
autres otages
si ma fille que vous
là est due à la restriction la réduction
des déplacements et non pas encore au
vaccin
l'effet de la vaccination interviendra
plus tard
alors on a bien compris un les cas
positifs baisse en année cas de
contamination baisse
est-ce que les cas de décès baisse
également et peut-être que là on
pourrait ressentir les effets de la
vaccination puisque on le rappelle tout
même quinze millions de britanniques ont
déjà été vaccinées ça fait beaucoup de
monde y est sauf because des
vaccinations la vaccination s'est
concentré sur les personnes très
vulnérables
que ce soit en raison de la rage de la
situation sanitaire
donc le taux de décès devrait bientôt
commencer à tomber également et les
personnes les plus âgées qui seront
contaminées pourrait ne pas nourrir à
l'avenir secteur je commence à constater
certains bénéfices les gens semblent
montrer une certaine protection suite à
l'injection du vaccin
il comptera que la maladie mais ne
développent pas de forme grave qui les
envoient à l'hôpital
est ce que vous constatez justement vous
sur le terrain des effets secondaires ou
globalement cette campagne de
vaccination se passe plutôt bien au
royaume uni le solde
les effets secondaires on s'y attendait
des douleurs au niveau de l'injection de
la fatigue des maux de tête pendant
quelques jours ce ne sont pas des effets
secondaires sérieux
autant que nous sachions certes il ya
certains cas mais en règle générale la
campagne de vaccination se déroule très
bien et lune
raison de ce succès c'est que pour
changer le gouvernement du royaume uni à
tirer parti à utiliser les systèmes
existants du nhs avec par exemple des
médecins généralistes
la leçon à retenir ici c'est que si l'on
se sert des experts locaux tels gens qui
connaissent bien la situation alors il
ya de meilleurs résultats avec moins de
besoin alors les vaccins et les variants
aussi on les craint toujours d'ailleurs
un nouveau variant a été découvert
baptisé b15 25 ce n'est pas exactement
comment il prononça pour être honnête
repérez également sur le territoire
français est ce que vous le connaissez
vous est-ce qu'il est plus virulent que
les autres j'ai conservé ma
méconnaissance et toutes qu'elles vont
apparaître ces îles le fonctionnement
naturel de ce type de virus en un seul
type lien serait plus qu il y à des
erreurs et ainsi le virus acquiert par
ses erreurs un avantage reproductif
alors ce variant elle devient est la
forme dominante en circulation donc je
souhaite c'est bien dire aux gens qu'ils
peuvent en être certain malgré le
variant la plupart des vaccins semble
rester efficace semble toujours protéger
contre de formes graves de la maladie
donc le vaccin reste protecteur malgré
les variants et le vaccin protège contre
le virus d'origine mais également contre
les variants empêche de développer des
femmes est grave
varian si un rayon très différent
apparaît alors nous pouvons toujours
changer la forme de vaccin afin de mieux
protéger contre ce variant spécifiques
alors malgré un scénario dont vous
parlez lueur d'espoir ça nous vient de
l'om est-ce qui a affirmé il y avait
hier que le nombre de cas avait reculé 1
les quatre qu'ovide de 16% sur une
semaine globalement dans le monde
comment doit-on prendre cette bonne
nouvelle avec prudence
oui il faut rester prudents et il faut
reprendre cette expression utilisée
s'inscrit il y a très longtemps en
indien qui signifie le monde est une
famille
nous devons rester lui et agir comme si
le monde entier était une famille unique
il ne suffira pas à d'immuniser tous les
pays riches d'europe et des états unis
tout en laissant de côté l'afrique et
l'asie nous devons elysées protéger
toutes les populations en parallèle
c'est ainsi que nous aurons moins des
variants et c'est ainsi que le monde
entier sera mieux protégé contre les
nouveaux variants alors puisque vous
parlez d'asie que vous venez de citer un
problème
un proverbe d'inde un dernier mot sur ce
pays comment expliquez-vous que l'un
d'eux soit plutôt épargné par cette
deuxième vague sans restriction dans le
pays
oui donc non c'est un mystère
scientifique et pourquoi se porte-t-elle
si bien si soudainement fac pour moi je
pense qu'il ya plusieurs facteurs tout
d'abord la population est plus jeune
ensuite c'est peut-être que leur système
immunitaire et plus
car il est confronté à beaucoup et 2
d'infection il ne faut pas oublier
également le soleil est également
possible que cela soit une modification
temporaire en vertu des températures à
cette période de l'année
donc effectivement l'inde a beaucoup de
chance pour le moment cela pourrait
changer très soudainement non leur soit
de quoi évidemment on souhaite qu'il
reste dans cet état de grâce merci à
baratte up en khâgne un expert en
maladies infectueuses à l'université
d'exeter merci d'avoir été avec nous la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
réclame la libération immédiate d'alexei
navalni l'opposant russe incarcéré pour
violation des conditions de son sursis
alors comment la russie at elle
accueilli la décision de la cod h lun
correspondance à moscou d'antoine
cléroux du côté des partisans d'alexina
vanille et de ses avocats en premier
lieu on estime que les autorités russes
ont le devoir de se plier au jugement de
cette cour
la russie ayant ratifié en 1981 18 la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme en revanche les autorités russes
ne voit pas les choses de la même façon
on jauge à moscou qu'il n'existe aucune
base légale dans le droit russe qui
permettent la libération d'alexina
vanille et qu'il s'agit là d'une
ingérence grossière
nous estimons que cette décision est un
nouvel élément de la campagne de
pression sur notre pays notamment un
élément d'ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures de notre pays
d'ailleurs selon le ministère de la
justice il s'agit de pression et
d'ingérence dans le système judiciaire
de notre pays ce sont les maillons d'une
seule et même chaîne mais il y a un
autre aspect fondamental c'est une salve
tirée contre le droit international dont
les conséquences à mon avis échappe à la
cee d h
ils détruisent le fondement le fondement
du droit international qu'ils n'ont pas
créée mais qui sert de base aux
relations internationales contemporaines
les états faisant partie de la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme ont l'obligation de respecter
les mesures adoptées par la cour même si
dans les faits le non-respect de telles
décisions a déjà été observée
rappelons également qu entre 2014 et
2019 la russie avait été écarté des
travaux du conseil de l'europe dont
dépend cette cour à la suite du
rattachement de la crimée ce dernier
contentieux illustre donc une nouvelle
fois la dégradation ray
santes et profonde des relations entre
la russie et l'union européenne alors
que sont à l'étude de nouvelles
sanctions contre moscou on a les chefs
de la diplomatie français allemand
britannique et américain souhaite que
l'iran revienne en plein respect de ses
engagements nucléaires ils se sont
concertés aujourd'hui en visioconférence
et préviennent d'une même voix limiter
l'accès des inspecteurs de l'aiea serait
dangereux une réunion dont l'objectif
était de trouver un dénouement a faim
défaire de faire revenir les états unis
dans l'accord après avoir cité durant le
mandat de donald trump
mais lire on demande d'abord à ce que
les états unis lèvent les sanctions
envers le pays
une issue doit être trouvé avant le 21
février écouter heiko maas chef de la
diplomatie allemande
nous qui avons maintenu cet accord en
vigueur ces dernières années et il
s'agit maintenant d'aider les états unis
à reprendre le chemin de l'accord et
cela devra finalement être décidées à
washington et les mesures qui ont été
prises à téhéran et qui entreront en
vigueur dans les prochains jours sont
donc tous au futile
il met en danger le chemin des
américains vers cet accord plus la
pression exercée est forte plus il sera
politiquement difficile de trouver une
solution
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
hassan madjed fondateur de ds consulting
cabinet d analyse sur le moyen-orient
bonsoir assad mais deviennent merci
d'être avec nous tairons qui déclare
donc qu'il respectera ses engagements de
l'accord sur le nucléaire à condition
que les états unis lèvent leurs
sanctions économiques
de son côté washington qui exige que
l'iran respecte le deal de 2015 c'est un
dialogue de sourds
oui et non parce que si les deux acteurs
souhaitent pas revenir en fait à un
accord
toutefois chacun d'eads était plutôt des
trois belligérants savoir les états unis
l'iran et l'union européenne
à chacun ses difficultés si du côté
américain on a plusieurs personnes au
sein de l'administration biden comme
jack sullivan robert mallet qui ont
participé dans les négociations du jce
ipo et font désormais partie donc de
l'administration de biden
toutefois il est nécessaire donc il ya
plusieurs difficultés côté américain à
savoir réintégrer l'accord est aussi
convaincre les autres partisans comme
par exemple notamment donc les
républicains qui étaient réticents donc
après l'administration obama
et le mark était comme en tant que ce
qu'on appelle by partition agreements
est à dire qu un accord bi partisan vous
qui permettrait à la corde être dans le
d'être donc durable dans le temps côté
iranien
si donc il y à une impérativité à
l'impératif de parvenir à un accord pour
l'administration alfani toutefois il y à
des pressions qui sont en interne mais
il allait il ya une impérative de
parvenir à un accord notamment afin
avant les élections prochaines iranienne
devenue 21 juin en fin juin 2021 côté
européen
l'ensemble des belligérants donc savoir
la france l'angleterre l'angleterre à
l'allemagne ils sont un peu ton temps
entre les deux voies ces trois nations
n'ont pas pu donc instaurer un mécanisme
qui permettrait de temps dure la part de
l'accord notamment donc à travers l'ong
les mécanismes commerciaux dienst ex qui
n'ont pas permis en fait à à l'iran de
survivre lors des quatre années 30 mais
d'un autre côté en fait ces nations lin
sont en train de conserves de prendre
connaissance que le jce purée à vendre
durant l'administration obama n'est pas
le même et qui font tenir compte d'un
ensemble de changements qui sont dans le
contexte géopolitique notamment donc
l'apparition de plusieurs de nouveaux
axes comme la kz israélo émirati ou
encore le fait de comprendre les
craintes des dépit sand et des autres
nations de la région
les etats unis les européens la chine et
la russie veulent tout et on l'a dit
pour veulent tout faire pour faire
sauver l'accord la russie qui a de
bonnes relations avec l'iran à ce
qu'elles peuvent servir de médiateur
dans ce dossier selon vos besoins la
russie et la chine je pense que les deux
nations ont des cartes pour jouer donc
l'intermédiaire entre guillemets lawn
est procureur com quels termes qui a
employé le plus souvent par notamment
par le président macron notamment à
cause
des différents accords conclus entre les
deux pays et les intérêts stratégiques
qui les unissent notamment en syrie et
en irak
donc je pense que la russie pourrait
jouer ce rôle puisque les européens en
ce moment alors en juin des élections
présidentielles vont avoir lieu en iran
pour élire le successeur de roy ni est
ce que ça peut changer la donne si un
accord est parvenu les réformistes ronde
donc les réformistes auront de quoi
marquer tu es leur prochaine la
prochaine élection à savoir le fait de
dialoguer avec les oxydants autrement on
doit par an doit s'attendre à un
président qui est du côté dont étaient
des conservateurs alors une levée des
sanctions américaines sur l'économie
iranienne pourrait permettre à au camp
modéré en tout cas d'être d'accéder au
pouvoir n'est ce pas aussi dans
l'intérêt finalement des états unis que
de lever ses sanctions
exactement parce que le fait d'avoir un
conservateur en face style monsieur
raïssi ou encore monsieur qalibaf qui a
encore la tête de la mairie terran qui
pour certains est l'étape pour parvenir
à la à la présidence pourrait rendre le
dialogue
un peu plus difficile et donc durer
encore un peu plus de temps toutefois
regardez donc le côté positif on ne peut
pas nier qui est actuellement à des
négociations secrètes entre les deux
nations
soit de manière directe dans une course
dans un terreau ce pays comme ça c'était
le cas à oman avant que l'administration
obama ne puisse réussir des élections
est actuellement on a plusieurs
candidats qui peuvent servir
d'intermédiaire comme par exemple le
sultanat d'oman qui l'a déjà fait le
guen qu'il a déjà proposé ou encore la
diplomatie qatarie qui est qui en train
de monter en grade de reprendre de
l'activité notamment après donc l'
annonce de la fin de la crise du du
coach
merci à sanaa d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france
les projets de l'entrepreneur américain
elon musk remis en cause par un village
normand sa société space x où est
implantée une station relais à saint
senier de beuvron dans le département de
la manche
il faut dire que le projet est loin
d'être accueilli à bras ouverts à maya
souple et saint senier de beuvron fait
de la résistance ce petit village du
nord ouest de la france a récemment été
choisi par l'entreprise space x objectif
pour la compagnie américaine il
développer les infrastructures servant à
relier ces satellites et y développer
son réseau internet haut débit à
destination du monde entier le village
qui possède déjà la fibre constitue un
lieu d'implantation idéal pour la firme
du richissime elon musk problème le
projet semble très loin de faire
l'unanimité au sein de la population
ce projet donc on l'a refusée parce
qu'on avait eu un manque d'information
au niveau de la santé la santé humaine
mais aussi de la santé animale car nous
sommes quand même dans un milieu très
rurale et avec le beaucoup
d'agriculteurs autour de nous on sait
que ça peut jouer sur le sur la
production laitière ça peut diminuer la
production laitière et malheureusement
visuellement ça ne se voit pas donc on a
et on va pas de recul pour savoir ce qui
est bon ce qui est bravo brenoux congrès
pour les animaux quoi une zone rurale de
350 habitants de nombreuses
exploitations une activité agricole
incontournable le projet a de quoi
inquiéter les habitants les informations
sur les effets des ondes sur la santé et
la production locale demeure trop floue
aux yeux de ce conseiller régional ces
champs électromagnétiques pose déjà des
interrogations aux élevages qui sont
déjà beaucoup impacter les dom terrestre
qui serait implantée dans les sous sols
en zone humide avec des nappes
phréatiques de surfaces ou des nappes
profondes à quelques mètres des cours
d'eau ce sont des choses qui méritent
d'être expertisée starling souhaitait
acquérir trois hectares et y installer
plusieurs données lectrique ainsi que
des antennes de trois mètres de haut
selon les écologistes
pour l'heure ce projet à mi chemin entre
avranches et fougères
a recueilli l'unanimité contre lui au
conseil municipal du village
mais la firme d'outre-atlantique
disposerait de deux autres options pour
implanter ses activités sur le
territoire dans le nord et en gironde
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la procédure de
dissolution engagée par le ministère de
l'intérieur contre génération
identitaire le groupe d'ultra droite
dénonce une décision politique et
appelle à manifester à paris ce samedi
alors faut-il dissoudre ce mouvement
politique nous en débattrons avec nos
invités
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va te suicider ça
ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides
la loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà
interdit de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est
juste que le légat fall ne l'appliquent
pas la justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et no line quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et big
for donc les gaffes à s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce que
quelqu'un s'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à douala des entreprises
privées de prendre cette décision mais
ça doit être à la justice de prendre
cette décision
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coût
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous un oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata papa parents pata
pata
vous avez envie de faire ça mais il faut
que leur qu'istres groove la musique
c'est la traduction la plus poétique de
la vie si vous mettez pas la vie des
vides à mon sens bête
il faut sortir les notes de leurs
univers carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui a entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre
le peuple a tenté une volonté collectés
vous le savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit
il n'y a pas d'alternative on sent du
politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï ce gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit on doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
un certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement a percuté et on ne peut
pas considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et notre étude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité si
le sentiment d'exister d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde est
vrai que la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
des accords d'abraham changer
l'équilibré stratégique pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complexe preuve était
le seul à pouvoir créer un mission d'une
paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qu'une ira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accros de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
la minustah elle compte au moins
quatorze militaires et policiers
déployés au maniement s'est-elle face
c'est une mission de paix des nations
unies
mais la vérité c'est qu'elle est
reconnue dans un angle difficile
contemporaine n'est ni un ennemi
invisible un ennemi qu'il est prônée par
son vieux qui ne connaît la précarité
qui est là pour faire du mal mais grâce
à notre détermination nous sommes très
différents
on a le sentiment que c'est une guerre
perpétuelle dans le sel pour les
terroristes quel est votre constat la
menace et le risque d'une menace pour le
bas et que sa réponse doit être plus
souvent là et la solidarité
robin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous cet
écho positif n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent la haine en soi vient
de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
sujet de la société tous les témoins de
notre époque sont dans la grande
interview
[Musique]
21h heure française merci nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 18 février
manifestation de génération identitaires
prévus ce samedi à paris objectif
contester la procédure de dissolution
engagée par le ministère de l'intérieur
une décision que l'organisation qui
s'est fait récemment remarqué pour ses
patrouilles anti migrants à la frontière
franco-espagnole juge avant tout
politique
le groupe d'ultra droite n'est plus que
quelques jours pour s'opposer à la
procédure en plein débat sur le
séparatisme un rayon sur le grill six
ans après le rachat d' alstom general
electric n'a pas respecté son engagement
de créer 1000 emplois et on a détruit
trois fois plus 80 salariés du site de
villeurbanne près de lyon vont assigner
le groupe américain devant la justice
française dans le cadre d'une action en
responsabilité en croire les prévisions
du fmi le ciel semble pourtant
s'éclaircir sur le front de l'économie
française en ce début d'année 2021 mais
derrière les gros type quelle est la
réalité de cette reprise en france comme
dans le reste de l'europe est elle à la
mesure du redémarrage en trombe qui se
profile aux états unis après le
spectaculaire redressement machine
ce sera l'objet de l'édito de
l'économiste jacques sapir
[Musique]
le mouvement génération identitaire
contre attaque alors qu'il est sous le
coup d'une procédure de dissolution
lancée par le ministre de l'intérieur le
groupe d'ultra droite appellent à
manifester ce samedi à paris objectif
contester la décision de gérald darmanin
qu'il juge politique plus de détails sur
cette organisation controversée avec
théo combat génération identitaire deux
mots qu'on pourrait croire synonyme de
coup médiatique dans ce groupe d'ultra
droite est devenu spécialiste en la
matière
dernier coup d'éclat en date le 19
janvier lorsqu'une trentaine de
militants se sont lancés dans une
opération anti migrants à la frontière
espagnole
des actes qui ont provoqué la colère du
ministre de l'intérieur qui a
effectivement été particulièrement
scandalisé par le travail ces jeux se
dire de sape de la république
des militants de génération identitaire
qui ne sont pas à leur premier coup
d'éclat c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
j'ai donc demandé à sa milice à
l'intérieur de réunir les éléments qui
permettraient aux militants à 0 2
proposera des solutions de génération
identitaire je sais que les ministères y
travaillent
il ne sera évidemment dans le cadre des
lois et des règlements de la république
en proposant notamment une fois que ces
éléments seront particulièrement réunit
le contradictoire est dû à chaque
association
une procédure qui a donc été lancé le 13
février dernier
cette association a longtemps été la
branche jeune du mouvement bloc
identitaire
fondée en 2002 c'est en 2012 que le
mouvement est lancé officiellement et
commence à faire parler de lui
cette même année certains de ses membres
envahissent le toit d'une mosquée en
construction à poitiers fort d'un
certain succès médiatique
les opérations coup de poing
s'enchaînent rassemblement en 2017
devant le bataclan pour je cite la
défense de l'europe face aux islamistes
intrusion en 2018 dans un local de
l'association sos méditerranée qui vient
en aide aux migrants mais son principal
coup médiatique intervient lors d'une
vaste opération anti migrants à la
frontière alpine entre la france et
l'italie en avril 2010
8 une opération qui avait poussé dès
2019 plusieurs associations a demandé la
dissolution de ce groupe comme la ligue
internationale contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme des demandes validées
donc par la procédure enclenchée par
gérald darmanin au grand dam des
responsables de génération identitaire
cette lettre est plein d'inexactitudes
d'erreurs factuelles de mensonges et
d'un tas d'éléments qui n'ont pas leur
place dans une procédure de dissolution
si le droit est jugé nous sommes
extrêmement confiants
si par contre c'est une décision
politique et qu'il y ait un jugement
politique l'a effectivement nous avons
tout à craindre que la dissolution aille
à son terme
l'organisation qui a dix jours pour
fournir des contre-arguments au
ministère de l'intérieur devrait
effectuer ce qui pourrait être son
dernier baroud d'honneur samedi
génération identitaire souhaite lancer
une manifestation pour dénoncer c'est un
potentiel dissolution alors question
faut il dissoudre ce mouvement
génération identitaire c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
très fort en débatte nous sommes avec
david guiraud porte-parole jeunesse la
france insoumise bonsoir bonsoir david
guiraud merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés clément martin porte-parole
génération identitaire qu'on a vu
s'exprimer dans ce sujet alors clément
martin votre groupe et donc montrée du
doigt depuis une semaine par le ministre
de l'intérieur et en riposte vous
organisez donc une manifestation samedi
à paris vous avez pas un petit peu peur
que ça soit pris pour de la provocation
pourquoi cette manifestation absolument
pas d'ailleurs c'est une manifestation
qui est autorisé par la préfecture donc
qu'ils respectent parfaitement la
légalité comme à notre habitude
d'ailleurs et ce sera donc une grande
manifestation comme vous avez pu le dire
qui aura lieu samedi à 14 heures place
denfert rochereau où nous attendons
beaucoup de monde pour nous soutenir et
pour dénoncer cette décision décision
qui est parfaitement scandaleuse et puis
nous souhaitons bien entendu manifester
au delà de génération identitaire pour
la liberté d'expression et la liberté
d'association
ils sont gravement remise en cause
actuellement on va en parler évidemment
david guiraud une fois n'est pas coutume
j'imagine que vous soutenez gérald
darmanin
en quoi est ce important pour vous de
dissoudre ce mouvement en quoi est il
plus dangereux qu'un autre selon vous
écoutez nous demandent depuis longtemps
la dissolution de génération identitaire
d'ailleurs notre député eric coquerel on
avait déjà fait la demande il ya
plusieurs années
si vous savez pas mon avis génération
identitaire n'aurait même pas dû exister
est ce que vous savez par exemple que
c'est un groupe qui est née après la
dissolution du groupe unité radicale
unité radicale c'est un groupe qui a été
dissous à la suite de la tentative
d'assassinât d'extrême droite sur
jacques chirac en 2002 les origines de
génération identité reviennent du
terrorisme d'extrême droite et
d'ailleurs on pourrait aussi dire que
génération et dentaire se nourrit du
terrorisme d'extrême droite pourquoi
parce que par exemple vous avez brendon
40 qui est la personne qui a tué 50
personnes en attaquant une mosquée à
christchurch vous connaissez cet
attentat terrible qui a fait des dons à
génération identitaire et on pourrait
dire oh mais c'est pas de la faute de
génération identitaire ils n'y sont pour
rien mais si parce qu'ils soutiennent la
même idéologie de mort cette idéologie
qu'ils s'appellent par exemple le grand
remplacement moi je me suis j'ai vu je
me renseigne beaucoup sur ça voyez par
exemple ça c'est une conférence que
génération identitaire organise avec ses
petits amis où il ya monsieur martin
d'ailleurs et monsieur martin et ses
amis disent par exemple ils l'affirment
quand il soumet entre entre fascistes
que ils reprennent la théorie du grand
remplacement qui a justifié le meurtre
de 50 personnes à christian vous savez
d'ailleurs que brendon tard en ce
terroriste avant de perpétuer sa tuerie
a envoyé un manifeste notamment à la
première ministre australienne qui
s'appelait le grand remplacement je vous
en laisse ce je vous laisse juge de ça
mais surtout génération identitaire
c'est pas juste les musulmans ou celle
dont on parle beaucoup de la mosquée de
poitiers mais c'est aussi les juifs ce
groupe est foncièrement foncièrement
fondamentalement antisémite par exemple
monsieur martin doit bien connaître ce
monsieur qui s'appelle pierre loti si je
si je ne me trompe pas
pierre loti qui est qu'il doit bien
connaître parce que c'était d'un des
porte parole de générations identitaire
il ya quelques années il disait que les
juifs je le cite un les juifs ont
vocation à retourner dans leur pays
je ne sais pas quels pays c'est pour les
juifs qui sont en france depuis le
xiième siècle mais en tout cas c'est une
des déclarations de génération
identitaire je vais m'arrêter là pour
l'instant parce qu'il ya d'autres choses
à dire c'est qu'à génération identitaire
il ya beaucoup de criminels de gens qui
sont condamnés pour des faits de
violence donc ça fait longtemps que
génération identitaire haute et aurait
dû être dissous et vous savez bon ils
vont manifester ils seront pas beaucoup
mais c'est normal parce que je pense que
ça ne correspond pas à la france
le projet qu'ils défendent la france ce
sont d'autres valeurs ce sont des
valeurs de respect des autres et puis
surtout pas de haine comme ils peuvent
le défendre clément martin votre réponse
eq c'est déjà la conclusion notamment
est totalement fausse nous sommes bien
davantage que mon contradicteur
l'expression de la majorité une majorité
des français est favorable à la fin de
l'immigration massive
une majorité des français est favorable
à l'instauration de la préférence
nationale que nous avons défendues par
exemple lorsque nous avons occupé une
caf dans le 93
je pourrai ainsi multiplier les exemples
les français sur les questions
identitaires les questions
d'islamisation des questions
d'immigration sont très largement
d'accord avec muscles arcens sondages
après sondages et enquêtes après enquête
ça c'est certain que effectivement vous
dites est ce qu'il est mais les sondages
sont faux il n'y a pas 60
pour info c'est que les français nous
avions ce monsieur les français je vais
vous dire si vous si vous me permettez
si vous permettez les français ne sont
pas favorables
je vais vous le dire et je le construis
de remettre sincèrement s'il vous plaît
oui je vais répondre à monsieur les
français les français ne sont pas
favorables monsieur martin à ce que dans
vos bastion par exemple à lille c'était
un des gains de vos passions qui
s'appelle la citadelle à ce que l île
des gens parlent de faire des projets
d'attentats sur du marché sur des
marchés en contre des mosquées
ça ce sont des gens de votre
organisation les français ne sont pas
favorables à ce que vos cadres
politiques par exemple monsieur
verhassel à lyon savez vous que monsieur
varas elle a quand même été condamné à
cinq mois de prison ferme pour violences
et port d'armes est ce que vous savez
que par exemple à lyon
monsieur marc à la flèche est un des
cadres de général salon identitaire
allié clé matin apparemment on va pas
parler en même temps clément martin pour
la réponse sont justement ces
accusations de violences
david niro de gizeh cette issue du
terrorisme d'ultra droite qu'est ce que
vous lui répondez sur ces accusations de
de violence est ce que votre mouvement
prône la violence et l'activisme
évidemment que non absolument pas
d'ailleurs il n'y a jamais eu de
condamnations devant les tribunaux à ce
sujet et par ailleurs pour répondre à
faire pour répondre sur la sphère de la
citadelle que met en avant mon
contradicteur
je suis parfaitement à l'aise sur ce
sujet pour deux raisons la première
c'est que la citadelle est une
organisation indépendante
je leur apprends les identitaires
premier point et deuxième point les
personnes verra sa fille dans le rapport
absolument pas le dans le reportage que
vous mentionnez les personnes qui
tiennent des propos absolument
condamnable par ailleurs n'y a aucun
problème là dessus ne sont ni aveyron ni
membre de génération identitaire ça ne
sert à rien d'essayer de tout à leur
accorder fait que monsieur olivier marc
à la flèche
si oui mais vous monopolisé la parole on
peut s'accorder sur le fait que monsieur
olivier marin la flèche c'est bien un
cadre de chez vous un cadre de
génération identitaire à lyon on peut
bien s'accorder sur le fait qu'il a été
condamné pour avoir donné des coups de
couteau au sol sur des personnes
mineures et que c'est bien quelqu'un qui
vient de chez vous près de son local la
traboule à lyon ouais donc c'est près de
son local politique c'est quelqu'un qui
fait ce genre de choses aurélien vert à
celle qui est un de vos proches
également a été condamné à de la prison
ferme pour avoir agressé des gens vous
est imparti une organisation de repris
de justice de criminels d'antisémite de
raciste c'est la vérité c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que c'est difficile a avoué
pour vous mais je suis bien renseigné
vous savez sur votre organisation et
c'est la raison précise et lens pour
laquelle nous demandons depuis longtemps
votre dissolution année moi messieurs
c'est vrai que les personnalités plutôt
à droite soutiennent ce mouvement
génération identitaire elles sont contre
cette volonté de gérald darmanin de la
dissoudre
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il ya pas d
question a soulevé à débattre vous
propose de regarder ce commentaire tout
d'abord du président des patriotes
florian philippot sur les réseaux
sociaux
la dissolution de génération identitaire
n'est fondée sur aucun motif légal mais
sur une pure question d'opinion
la justice ne pourra qu'annuler cette
dissolution politique si elle ne la
nulle pa on saura officiellement qu'on a
basculé en tyrannie règne de
l'arbitraire pure et david guiraud sur
cette question de censure est ce qu'on
peut condamner des idées en france oui
on peut condamner les idées racistes
comme je voulais dit on peut condamner
les idées antisémites parce que quand on
déclare que les juifs ont vocation à
rentrer chez eux et que le programme
politique de génération identitaire
c'est d'aider les juifs ne veut pas
d'aidé de forcer les juifs français à
rentrer je ne sais vous probablement en
israël j'imagine c'est antisémite c'est
un délit le fait de recevoir des dons
d'organes de terroristes et de et de
prôner des idéologies comme le grand
remplacement qui sont utilisés pour
faire des tueries de masse comme celle
de brendon 40
c'est illégal en france ce n'est pas
permis vous voyez c'est pas parce que la
justice a pas encore condamné des gens
que ce qu'ils font est légale et par
ailleurs les opérations notamment à la
frontière c'est une usurpation des
compétences de l'état mais vous savez
c'est pas ça le plus grave le plus grave
encore jeu
vous le dis c'est l'idéologie 16
potentiel terroriste de cette
organisation depuis qu'elle a été créée
et ensuite ce sont tous les délits deux
qui sont qui ne sont pas des délits
d'opinion être raciste est un délit en
france ne vous en déplaise être
antisémite c'est un délit en france ne
vous en déplaise être violent et émettre
des coups de couteau au sol à des
mineurs près de son local politique
c'est un délit en france et ça mérite la
dissolution en effet demain matin sur
ces accusations de racisme
d'antisémitisme quelle est votre réponse
tout simplement mon contrat dit fort à
un petit peu de mal avec la notion de
liberté d'expression manifestement nous
sommes hostiles à l'immigration massive
à l'islamisation et ce sont des opinions
qui sont parfaitement autorisé en france
dalhousie même si on l'espère la
symboliser de monsieur course sans me
remettre en cause cela mais monsieur
vous me faites frire vos prénoms
réligieuses avec au courant oui
d'ailleurs notre avocat s'appelle m
goldnadel ça ne vous aura pas échappé si
vous êtes un antisémite je doute qu'ils
nous auraient défendu le joaillier tu as
grandi pas s'agrandir poser une question
vous êtes le représentant des jeunes de
la france a soumises vos députés dont
vous semblez très fier ont défilé avec
malice du ccf lors de la manifestation
contre l'islamophobie ccf qui est donc
mouillé en relation avec des entreprises
terroristes djihadistes donc si vous
voulez vos leçons de morales paraissait
très geek année donc avant d'entrer dans
l'eau trois ans si le jeune bosnien donc
c'est très intéressant
si je comprends bien vous êtes pour
dissoudre le ccf parce que vous dites
que soit disant il a des liens avec des
entreprises terroristes
vous ne savez pas lesquels par ailleurs
mais c'est pas grave vu que vous pouvez
pas le prouver mais par contre vous qui
avez des liens et recevez des
financements directs de terroristes qui
ont tué 50 morts notamment en australie
vous ne devez pas et dissout c'est donc
ça votre argument est ce que je le
comprends bien fait parce que d'autant
plus que déjà le virement en l'opion
vous allez être dissous le virement
auquel vous faites référence nous avons
eu effectivement ce virement
sauf qu'ils avaient été effectués des
années auparavant premier point est que
à l'époque
effectuez le terroriste en question
justement ne considérait pas faire le
genre d'actes qu'il a commis par la
suite par ailleurs pour des raisons qui
ne pas être évident et vous êtes
monsieur réussir vous êtes nos liens
avec l'organisation d'extrême droite et
des organisations terroristes à
l'international monsieur c'est tout mais
si vous justifiez la dissolution du ccf
par le fait qu'elle a vu quelqu'un qui
connaît qui a entendu parler d'eux et
qui a serré la main à quelqu'un d'autre
qui seraient en lien avec le terrorisme
monsieur je vous le dis vous êtes
parfaitement contradictoire puisque vous
êtes bien plus concerné par le
terrorisme d'extrême droite que le ccf
notre soutien pour faire un petit peu
avancer ce débat celui d'eric zemmour
éditorialistes souvent controversées
selon un dernier sondage 13% de
potentiel électoral éventuel
présidentielle sur un sondage de ifop je
vous propose d'écouter l'avis sur ce
point d'eric zemmour on ne fait rien
contre les femen qui envahissent
violemment des églises on ne fait rien
contre greenpeace qui envahit des
centrales nucléaires ce qui peut être
très dangereux on ne fait rien contre le
patron de la ligue de défense noire
africaine qui a traité les soldats
français morts au mali de terroristes
pourquoi ces gens là ne sont pas accusés
pourquoi ces associations ne sont pas
dissoute j'aimerais comprendre deux
poids deux mesures david guiraud
qu'est-ce que vous répondriez à eric
zemmour mais parce que justement moi je
vous le dit
la question n'est pour moi là qu'est ce
qui justifie la distribution de
génération identitaire ce n'est pas que
même si ça peut jouer ce n'est pas que
les opérations aux alpes ce ne sont pas
les actions coup de poing
c'est le potentiel terroriste l'histoire
terroristes et le fait qu'il y ait des
criminels au sein de cette organisation
qui agissent et qui frappent des gens
qui agressent des gens qui mettent des
coups de couteau aux gens et qu'ils sont
potentiellement dangereux pour la
sécurité publique c'est ça l'important
du débat ce ne sont pas que les
opérations aux actes évidemment usurpé
les fonctions de police et de garde des
frontières de la de la france c'est déjà
en soi un délit mais ce qui est le plus
délicieux skis le plus dommageable c'est
pas les actions avant un péquenot qu'ils
font c'est pas ça le problème ce sont
les propos antisémites
les propos racistes l'idéologie raciste
et potentiellement terroristes et le
fait que les cadres d'extrême droite de
génération identitaire mais vous savez
l'extrême droite qui n'arrête pas de
parler du terrorisme islamiste
c'est bien maintenant c'est prouvé cet
acte et il y à des sources et des
documentations là dessus qu'ils montrent
que par exemple vous aviez beaucoup de
gens d'extrême droite qui sont impliqués
dans l'été dans les attentats
terroristes islamiques je pense monsieur
herman qui étaient proches d'ailleurs
deux des identitaires à lille et à lyon
à monsieur armand c'est celui qui a
fourni des armes qui ont permis à mehdi
coulibaly de faire la prise d'otages et
la tuerie de l'hyper cacher pendant les
attentats terroristes ces gens là sont
connectés ils salaire va le terrorisme
islamique dont comprenez et moi ce que
je cherche à faire ça à éradiquer le
terrorisme islamiste et a dit y est art
et éradiquer le terrorisme d'extrême
droite et je trouve que génération
identitaire est justement au point de
convergence entre les deux ils se
nourrissent idéologiquement mais il se
il s'arme entre clément martin vous avez
donc dix jours votre association pour
apporter des éléments y répondre aux
contradicteurs pour ne pas être dissoute
cette dissolution d'associations a été
notifié le 12 février dernier
quelles vont être les arguments pour
vous maintenir en vie il y en a
plusieurs
essentiellement si on reprend la lettre
que nous avons reçu la lettre indique
que nous sommes dissous pour
essentiellement deux motifs un
l'incitation à la haine et de la
constitution d'une milice or pour par
exemple à fuyez le fait que nous serions
une milice le document mentionne
l'action de nos avions sel dans les
alpes en 2018 où nous avions recréer
symboliquement une frontière un site est
une action parfaitement pacifique et
d'ailleurs lors qu'il ya eu le procès
nous avons été intégralement relaxer au
mois de décembre dernier
donc il est déjà quand même intéressant
de constater que alors que nous avoir
été relaxé devant la justice cela
devient l'argument pour d'autres
dissolution il va sans doute poser un
certain nombre de problèmes juridiques
par ailleurs et on s'appuie également
sur l'opération que nous avons fait plus
récemment dans les pyrénées qui lui
ressemble et beaucoup opération pour
laquelle le préfet de haute garonne a
reconnu lui-même une avions commis aucun
trouble à l'ordre public
pardon et rien d'illégal donc là encore
ce sont donc des arguments qui sont
essentiellement bideau et pour ce qui
est de l'incitation à la haine
il nous est reproché l'action que nous
avions fait en 2012 lors du lancement du
mouvement en occupant le toit du
chantier de la mosquée de poitiers
procès qui s'est terminé par le
blanchissement de génération identitaire
qui a
nous n'avons eu aucune condamnation pour
cette action
donc la lettre si vous voulez regorge
des paiements ou ce triple a qui ne
tiennent absolument pas la route c'est
d'ailleurs je crise tous les arguments
utilisés ce soit par mon contradicteur
aucun d'eux figure dans la lettre en
question merci en tout cas à tous les
deux d'avoir apporté
oui bien sûr parce que je trouve que le
ministère de l'intérieur est faible dans
son attaque
évidemment moi je vous le dis quand vous
avez une organisation politique qui dit
que son programme c'est que les juifs
seront virés hors de france
je suis désolé c'est sur cette base
qu'il fallait attaquer quand vous avez
une organisation politique quand on
parle de milices c'est à dire de gens
armés c'est sur la base de gens armés
qui s'en prennent à des gens notamment
bas surtout des personnes issues de
l'immigration par exemple génération
identitaire pendant la coupe d'afrique
des nations des familles algériennes
c'est sur ces bases là qu'il faut les
attaquer en effet merci à tous les deux
clément martin david guiraud d'avoir
accepté ce débat en direct sur rt france
merci
reporters sans frontières demande aux
sénateurs de garantir la liberté des
journalistes l ong demandent au sénat la
suppression de l'article 18 du projet de
loi sur le séparatisme adopté il y a
deux jours par l'assemblée nationale
un article qui vise selon le secrétaire
général christophe deloire interdire la
diffusion malveillants d'image de
membres des forces de l'ordre à l'instar
de l'article 24 déjà remis en cause
rsf demande la suppression pure et
simple des deux articles pour empêcher
par la loi d'éventuels excès de pouvoir
comme l'article 24 l'article 18 pourrait
permettre que la diffusion d'image de
membres de forces de l'ordre par des
journalistes fassent l'objet de
poursuites
un procureur saisi d'une plainte
pourrait chercher à démontrer qu'elles
ont été diffusées par un journaliste
dans l'intention de nuire est difficile
pour dominique pradalié secrétaire
générale du syndicat national des
journalistes de ne pas voir aujourd'hui
une réelle intention de s'attarder sur
l'activité des journalistes qui a pas eu
de réelles intentions franchement ce
serait un peu étonnant de ne pas
l'imaginer car sans avoir de la paranoïa
dans nos gènes il faut bien reconnaître
qu'entre le schéma national du maintien
de l'ordre qui voudrait consacrer dit
avant chaque manifestation bien
gentiment auprès du préfet entre les
décrets du 2 décembre 2020 qui portent
atteinte directement à la protection des
sources des journalistes qui porte sur
le fait de recueillir des avis
politiques et syndicaux donc nous sommes
à doublement à double titre concerné si
on n'avait pas la paranoïa dans les
gènes on finirait par l'acquérir donc
bien évidemment toutes ces mesures qui
sont stigmatisés par toutes les
instances internationales et françaises
sont des mesures liberticides pour la
liberté d'informer et d'être informé des
par les citoyens la direction maintenant
la banlieue de lyon comme partout en
france le gouvernement a repoussé la fin
de la trêve hivernale jusqu'au 1er juin
pas suffisant pour certains qui
souhaitent tout simplement supprimer les
expulsions locatives jusqu'à la fin de
l'année
c'est le cas de michèle picard la maire
de vénissieux louis carballo avec
florian lambert interdire les expulsions
locatives en 2021 dans toute la france
c'est la proposition de la maire de
vénissieux et vice-présidente de la
métropole de lyon dans un courrier
adressé au premier ministre jean castex
michèle picard montent au créneau pour
venir en aide aux plus démunis
alors que la crise sanitaire continue de
battre son plein
je trouve que mettre des gens à la rue
sans relogement c'est inadmissible dans
une société comme la nôtre est encore
plus sont prises sanitaire parce que on
sait que les gens qui sont à la rue
masson sont encore plus sont encore plus
fragilisés
la crise sanitaire a développé aussi une
crise économique une crise sociale sans
nom ce qui fait que du cours va avoir de
plus en plus de gens et on le voit le
secours populaire
la fondation abbé-pierre toutes ces
associations attire l'attention des
pouvoirs publics sur le
sur la précarité la pauvreté qui
s'accentue de jour en jour
hop même constat du côté de
l'association réseau d'alerté de
solidarité cette association de
vénissieux vient en aide aux personnes
affectées par les ordres d'expulsion
depuis 1997
son président andré mazuir est
catégorique la crise a empiré la
situation de ceux qui étaient déjà en
difficulté la crise économique et la
crise sociale
elle arrivait de toute façon on est en
été en 2019 et il y avait des prémices
pour que cette crise elle éclate la
crise sanitaire qui arrivait en 2020 a
rajouté je rajoutais donc de la
difficulté pour les familles et a permis
effectivement que les choses se
compliquent pour un certain nombre de
familles prévue pour le 1er avril 2021
le gouvernement à repousser la fin de la
trêve hivernale des expulsions locatives
au 1er juin pour permettre aux familles
les plus vulnérables d'affronter une
crise non seulement sanitaire mais aussi
économique et social restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons de
general electric six ans après le rachat
d' alstom le groupe américain n'a pas
tenu son engagement créer 1000 emplois
l'entreprise va être assigné devant la
justice par des salariés puis nous
parlerons de l'économie française en
2021 et perspectives de rebond ont été
revues à la hausse par le fmi mais
derrière les gros tickets les la réalité
de cette reprise
jacques sapir tentera de répondre à
cette question
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je réponds en
appartement on est énervé donner le
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent
moi je voudrais pas qu'on ait passé un
tour de tracteur avec nous que notre
campagne il faut savoir c'est une ville
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
accepter une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on s'en doutait qu
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens ne
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui le droit il doit éviter les
dérives idéologiques merci de le
souligner comment peut-on reconstituer
une sixième république qui ne soit pas
la double hic parlementaire ça se passe
en direct puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté toujours
merci de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est les
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que la france a été plus
mauvaise que beaucoup de nos payes et
étrangers nous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on va retrouver un équilibre en
faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham change les
équilibres stratégiques pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complexe tron était le
seul à pouvoir créer induction d'une
paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter le sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran tu n'iras les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accros de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
21h30 soit il est bienvenu en direct sur
rt france le transport aérien est l'un
des secteurs économiques les plus
touchés par la pandémie
le groupe air france klm vient
d'annoncer des pertes colossales de 7,1
milliards d'euros en 2020 du jamais vu
la crise qui touche toutes les
compagnies aériennes est aussi un impact
sur les emplois des explications de
mathilde romagnan le transport aérien en
plein crash l'année 2020 a été
catastrophique pour le secteur les
mesures sanitaires liés à la pandémie de
covile 19 ont cloué la plupart des
avions au sol
les chiffres sont vertigineux 66 % de
fréquentation en moins au niveau mondial
le chef économiste de l'iata
l'association internationale du
transport aérien brian pearce ne mâche
pas ses mots
c'est le plus gros choc que le secteur
aérien ait jamais vécu l'impact sur les
compagnies aériennes est colossal elles
ont perdu 5 110 milliards de dollars de
chiffre d'affaires en 2020 des pertes
financières qui auront aussi de graves
conséquences sur l'emploi
selon les estimations de l'iata à 40
compagnies aériennes sont sur le point
de disparaître en europe selon
l'european cockpit association environ
18000 postes de pilotes ont été
supprimés ou sont menacés sur 65 mille
les moyens de subsistance de 11,3
millions de personnes dans le monde
dépend directement de l'aviation 76,4
millions de jobs supplémentaires sont
dans le tourisme dépendant de l'aviation
impact qui se ressentira aussi sur
l'industrie aéronautique en france le
groupe airbus a baissé sa production de
près de 40% en 2020
l'avionneur américain boeing a encore
enregistré en janvier plus d'annulations
que de commandes d'avions et les
perspectives d'une embellie sont
limitées le groupe air france klm ne
s'attend pas à un regain de trafic avant
le
deuxième voire le troisième trimestre
2000 21 pour le transport aérien
le redécollage sera long toujours au
chapitre économique et sociale 80
salariés du site general electric de
villeurbanne ont porté plainte contre le
géant américain a lors du rachat de la
branche énergie d'alstom en novembre
general electric s'était engagé à créer
1000 emplois mais six ans après la
promesse n'a pas été tenue au contraire
le taux de création est négatif avec
3000 emplois supprimés d'où l'action en
justice action responsabilité deux des
employés se sont exprimés sur cette
action micro d'rtl france aujourd'hui on
peut en suivi des plans de
restructuration à rallonge qui se
succèdent et on en arrive à a+ licenciés
qu'embaucher et c'est inacceptable
donc aujourd'hui on veut faire valoir ce
droit à contester et pouvoir et pouvoir
connaître et montrer des préjudices
qu'ils ont subis
on se retrouve vraiment souffrance et on
s'inquiète encore de l'avenir même si se
paie cela n'est pas terminé on
s'inquiète déjà de l'avenir et de des
prochaines choses qui vont arriver
il est confiant et images la chose en
disant que c'est des engagements qui
sont qui n'ont pas été tenues comme nous
nous soyons si aujourd'hui on devait
tenir des engagements on les tient pas
on serait sanctionné la place est pareil
c'est pas parce que jean eric trick à
payer 50 millions à l'état qu'ils ont le
droit de détruire 100 personnes et les
familles qui sont qui sont avec donc
aujourd'hui on est 80 se manifester on
espère qu'on sera plus parce qu'on est
beaucoup beaucoup plus impactés il ya un
gros des engagements on est en cs
aujourd'hui sur l'aspect social de la
restructuration
90% des salariés de grid ne croient plus
aux enjeux de l'entreprise consiste à
dire ils ne sont plus dans le dans le
discours de la direction quoi il ya un
désengagement est une des missions entre
guillemets des des salariés de
l'entreprise et du management il ya
derrière cette cette procédure il ya
aussi une demande forte au niveau des
organisations syndicales que le
gouvernement fasse appliquer un certain
nombre de deux
deux choses de promesses qui tient c'est
à dire de garder des activités
essentielles en france et aujourd'hui
nos activités de transport d'électricité
font partie des activités essentielles
et general electric est en train de s'en
séparer en france progressivement quoi
ces salariés sont défendus par l'avocat
fiodor rilov spécialiste en plans
sociaux et s'était occupé notamment des
affaires sony les 3 suisses ou encore
coca cola nous sommes en direct avec
luis bonsoir fidor il offre merci à
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
une action en responsabilité qu'est ce
que cela veut dire exactement
écoutez il ya des responsables de la
catastrophe sociale qui est en train de
se produire chez général elektriks à
villeurbanne mais pas seulement à
villeurbanne sur beaucoup d'autres sites
celui de belfort aussi bien sûr et les
responsables il faut les faces
sanctionné parce que c'est très simple
ce qui s'est produit chez general
electric à l'origine toutes ses usines
étaient des usines alstom les salariés
travailler pour alstom et général
electrics est venu racheter ses civic
c'est infrastructures industrielles et
évidemment commence à toucher des
intérêts stratégiques de la france
puisque ses usines fabriquent des
outil extrêmement important pour compris
la défense il a fallu que général
elektriks s'engage au moment du rachat à
maintenir ses activités en france et
aussi à maintenir les salariés dans
leurs emplois
et puis ils sont même allés plus loin au
moment de la vente
général elektriks a dit franchement
n'ayez aucune inquiétude
nous allons nous engager à créer 1000
emplois en plus de ce qui existe au
moment où nous devenons propriétaire de
ses usines
donc évidemment tout le monde à ce
moment là à considérer
parce que s'était couché sur papier il
ya un contrat qui a été con que ses
engagements à l'être tenu que général
elektriks allait effectivement augmenté
le nombre de salariés à l'intérieur de
ses usines en france
qu'est-ce-qui conclure de contrat donc
feeder rilov
comment quels sont les arguments avancés
par par l'entreprise justement pour
justifier cette rupture de contrat et le
non respect de sa promesse avant de
parler de ça il faut surtout souligner
que non seulement ils n'ont pas
construit d'emplois supplémentaires ils
n'ont pas augmenté le nombre de postes
dans l'usiné mais ils ont fait
exactement le contraire de ce qu'il
avait promis
ils ont supprimé des emplois ça fait des
années qu'ils détruisent par centaines
des postes à l'intérieur de ces usines
et ils font ça sans que quiconque ne
réagisse et
je dirais que dans lucky conquis a
surtout l'état qui d'une passivité
absolument incroyable et inacceptable
parce que lorsque general electric a
pris cet engagement de créer des emplois
un très précisément mille emplois l'état
a dit aux salariés
je serai le garant du respect de cette
promesse tarde général elektriks je suis
ici en quelque sorte le vigile en charge
de faire respecter cette promesse par
général elektriks et lorsque le groupe
étasunien commencé à détruire des
emplois donc encore une fois à faire le
contraire de ce à quoi il s'était engagé
l'état non seulement n'est pas
intervenue mais a participé d'une
certaine manière a posé un voile sur ces
événements et a accompagné du général
elektriks dans la violation de ses
engagements
et comme le disait le salarié tout à
l'heure l'action que nous avons engagées
elle a pour but c'est tout simple de
faire condamner celui qui a manqué à sa
promesse celui qui a violé ses
engagements à savoir de général
elektriks mais nous voulons aussi mettre
en lumière mettre en évidence l'attitude
de l'état qui est scandaleuse et qui a
fait lui aussi le contraire de ce qu'il
avait promis
non seulement il n'a pas garanti le
respect de ses engagements il n'est pas
intervenu pour contraindre alstom a
respecté sa promesse mais a aidé en
réalité alstom pardon de général
elektriks à a violé ses engagements a
violé sa promesse
ma question pardonnez moi si je peux
poser tout de même une question au
milieu comment vous expliquer l'attitude
justement du géant américain mais aussi
l'attitude très passive de l'état
écoutez moi explique ça de façon
relativement simple je crois que depuis
le début
l'état et l'état en l'occurrence en 2014
celui qui étonnait ses propos
extrêmement rassurant c'était ma promo -
voilà c'est lui qui était aux manettes
de cette opération
je crois que depuis le début ils ne
disent pas la vérité je crois que depuis
le début il savait que général elektriks
n'allait pas remplir ses engagements
on a jeté de la poudre aux yeux aux
salariés et pas seulement aux salariés
voilà tous les observateurs en faisant
croire qu'on allait être extrêmement
prudent et vigilant pour faire respecter
ses engagements par general electric ce
alors qu'en réalité on savait que le
groupe n'avait pas respecté ses
promesses allaient faire le contraire
détruire des emplois et l'attitude de
macron est-ce que franchement elle est
si étonnante que ça est ce que on peut
vraiment être surpris du fait qu' il a
fait dans cette affaire le contraire de
ce à quoi il s'était engagé lui aussi de
son côté
moi moi non je pense que c'est pas
surprenant parce que vous voyez
idéologiquement macron son gouvernement
tout se voit là qui participe à sa
politique estime que c'est bien qu'une
entreprise et surtout d'une grande firme
internationale puisse librement
licenciés en france que les usines et
même lorsque elle participe d'une
activité qui relève de l'intérêt
national puisse être démantelé voilà
parce que leur démantèlement permet à
quelques actionnaires de ces grandes
multinationales de faire encore
davantage de profits parce que ces
opérations de suppressions d'emplois de
démolition des usines ne sont pas en
quelque sorte de marche
voilà esthétique pour voilà ses
actionnaires qu'ils trouveraient ça
commence à
amusant de donner la question pardonnez
moi m il rénove que qu'espèrent les
plaignants et que peuvent-ils obtenir
selon vous ce sera ma dernière question
qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent obtenir
eh bien écoutez d'abord il peut faire
éclater la vérité au grand jour ce qui
est quand même pas mal et c'est ça
qu'ils veulent absolument ils veulent
que l'on puisse enfin mettre en évidence
que leur situation est le résultat d'une
violation patente spectaculaire est
inadmissible de promesses qui avaient
été garantis au plus haut niveau de
l'état
c'est évidemment leur premier objectif
et puis ben ils sont aujourd'hui à deux
doigts d'être licencié et donc ils vont
se retrouver au chômage ils vont subir
un préjudice chacun et chacune de ses
salariés va être dans une situation
économique extrêmement compliqué dans
les mois à venir et donc ils vont
évidemment demander réparation à ceux
qui sont les responsables
encore une fois de cette catastrophe qui
s'est produite il ya déjà quelques
années et qui est enfin dénoncée et je
crois que voilà il ya beaucoup de
salariés parmi ceux de general electric
qui n'ont pas encore rejoint la démarche
qui vont se décider à le faire et voilà
il justice sera rendue beaucoup fidor
rid of d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france merci et récession moins
forte que prévue en 2020 pourtant malgré
ces mauvaises nouvelles perspectives de
rebond révisé à la hausse par le fmi le
ciel bleu ciel on dirait pas semble
s'éclaircir pour l'économie française en
ce début d'année 2021 à mesure que
l'épidémie de kobe tu se stabilise dans
le monde mais derrière les gros tickets
les la réalité de cette reprise en
france comme d'ailleurs dans le reste de
l'europe est elle à la mesure du
redémarrage en trombe qui se profile aux
états unis après le spectaculaire
redressement des chine c'est l'objet de
notre édito échos ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir j'accepte qu'il ya merci d'être
avec nous bonsoir c'est fanny alors
récession moins forte que prévu le choc
de l'épidémie aurait donc été moins
grave que ce qui avait été annoncé
jacques oui tout à fait les derniers
chiffres donnent une récession une
dépression de -18 3%
c'est effectivement nettement moins que
ce que les économistes estiment et
jusqu'à maintenant
bruno le maire a parlé de -10% moi même
j'avais avancé des chiffres qui allait
jusqu'à -1 11%
donc oui d'une certaine manière les
chiffres sont beaucoup moins mauvais que
ce qui était prévu
maintenant il faut tout de suite dire
que une dépression de -8 3% dans une
année c'est quelque chose absolument
sans précédent en france ce sont des
chiffres qui sont de l'ordre de ceux de
la crise de 1929 donc néanmoins le choc
économique sur la france a été un choc
majeur est par ailleurs il faut aussi
dire que les l'ensemble du contexte
économique qui entoure ces chiffres est
très loin d'être rassurant alors avant
d'aller plus loin dans l'analyse jacques
peut-on dire sur les chiffres de 2020
alors sur 2020 si vous voulez l'ensemble
de l'économie mondiale a connu une
dépression très nette
une dépression qui est en moyenne de - 3
et demi pour cent donc on voit bien là
que la france se situe très en deçà en
réalité de la dépression mondiale
alors ce qu'on peut remarquer ces deux
choses premièrement le fait qu' il y a
deux zones qui ont été particulièrement
frappé la zone euro moins 7,2 pour cent
et l'amérique latine - 7,4 pour cent
ce sont des chocs qui sont extrêmement
avancé quant au contraire les économies
émergentes d'asie n'ont connu une
récession que deux moins 1,1 pour cent
donc ça c'est déjà
premier problème et puis la deuxième
chose qu'il faut dire c'est que à
l'évidence les économies avancées des
économies de vieilles industrialisation
en fait
eh bien ce sont les économies qui ont
connu des récessions qui sont très
largement supérieur à la moyenne
mondiale des récessions de l'ordre de -
5 % alors que la moyenne mondiale est à
moi trois et demi pour ça alors on est
curieux de savoir ce qui s'est passé
dans ces pays pour quelle raison
justement que s'est il passé
c'est là où il y a eu des choses très
intéressant parce que dans ces pays
deviennent industrialisation on voit
qu'il y a des différences assez
importantes entre pays par exemple
d'abord il ya les états unis alors les
états unis ils ont ils
ils ont moins souffert de la crise du
code vide que les autres pays et surtout
aujourd'hui ils connaissent 1re
démarrage en fanfare de l'économie qu'il
s'agisse du redémarrage de la
consommation ont bien entendu une
consommation qui a été boostée par
l'échec qui ont été données à tous les
ménages américains mais aussi la très
bonne résistance des économies du
numérique et des grands géants du
numérique les gaffes acquis sont
américains et enfin quelques dont on
parle assez peu
c'est le rebond de l'industrie prennent
pétrolière après si on regarde justement
en europe on voit qu'il y à deux
phénomènes qui sont très nets premier
phénomène c'est que un pays comme
l'allemagne et auquel on peut associer
le japon qui est un pays asiatique mais
dont la structure économique et
industriel est assez proche de l'anad
cpi ne résiste pas mal du tout
puisqu'ils sont autour de - 5 - 5 et 10%
par rapport à ces pays la france qu'on
associés d'ailleurs plutôt à ce type de
pays eh bien elle se retrouve très
décalé et elle se retrouve elle nous le
taux au niveau de pays comme l'italie
l'espagne voire le royaume uni
quiconque au nude et des pressions
extrêmement fortes
avec la crise sanitaire donc il ya aussi
une chose qui apparaît c'est aujourd'hui
une forme de divergences au sein des
pays industrialisés au sein et en
particulier des pays européens
on voit une divergence est en train de
s'ouvrir entre l'europe du nord et
l'europe du sud et la question cette
situation va-t-elle perdurer avec la
reprise alors là tout est fini vous avez
tout à fait raison parce que là ce sont
les chiffres sur 2020 donc il faut peut
être regarder aujourd'hui ce qui va se
passer sur l'avenir est là quand on
regarde les prévisions qui sont faites
par le fonds monétaire international
ce sont des chiffres qui ont été publiés
à la fin du mois de janvier mais qu'est
ce qu'on voit ben on voit que les
économies européennes allemagne france
espagne italie sont plutôt au bas du
graphique
elles ne retrouveront leurs niveaux de
2018 qu'en 2022 pour l'allemagne la
france et l'espagne
probablement 2023 seulement pour
l'italie alors que au contraire et bien
la chine et les économies émergentes
d'asie
elle caracole en tête ce qui fait peser
le risque d'une forme de déclassement de
l'europe 1 par rapport au pays d'alice
alors quand on est vous jacques par un
déclassement de l'europe
justement si vous voulez le fait que
l'europe et les états unis aussi
représentés dans les années 1950 1960 le
coeur de l'industrie le coeur de la
croissance en fait au niveau mondial et
qu'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui eh bien
on voit que l'union européenne qui en
2002 faisait à peu près 20% du pig
mondiale bon alors en parité de pouvoir
d'achat
eh bien il est tombé à 16 % en 2013 2014
et il tombera
si on en croit le fonds monétaire
international à 12% en 2022 par rapport
à ça ce que l'on constate aussi c'est
l'explosion littéralement
des pays d'asie émergente qui était à 17
% c'est-à-dire chou la part de l'union
européenne en 2002 qui ont atteint
grosso modo 30 % en 2013 2014 et qui
depuis 2019 et là encore si on croit les
prévisions du fmi vont continuer à
avancer très fortement puisqu'il devrait
atteindre en 2022 à peu près 42 % du pib
mondial
donc le déclassement c'est ça c'est le
fait que alors que l'union européenne et
les pays d'asie émergente faisait à peu
près jeu égal l'union européenne était
même au dessus des pays de l'asie
émergente en 2002 en 2022 donc vingt ans
après et bien l'union européenne ne
représentera plus que 30% de la part du
pib des pays d'asie émergente
c'est cela le déclassement alors jacques
peut-on espérer que le plan de relance
européen permettra justement d'inverser
cette tendance
si vous voulez là encore il y à ce qui
est dit et puis il ya la réalité un ce
plan il a il faut le rappeler il a été
adopté à l'été dernier donc à l'été 2020
il ne sera en réalité mis en oeuvre qu'à
l'été 2021 au mieux je dis bien au mieux
peut-être même ce sera plutôt vers la
fin de 2021 et alors qu'est ce qu'il
prévoit il prévoit grosso modo 750
milliards d'euros sur deux ans je dis
bien sûr deux ans alors que si on
regarde les sommes qui ont été dépensées
en 2020 donc sur une année les sommes
budgétaires qui ont été dépensés en 2020
pour sept pays eh bien on voit que c'est
ces pays de l'union européenne et sept
pays d'ailleurs de la zone euro eh bien
ils ont à eux c'est déjà dépensé plus de
760 milliards d'euros donc qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que un le plan
européen est très en deçà des besoins
de l'union européenne et de la zone euro
ces besoins ils ont d'ailleurs été
estimé par le parlement européen
autour de 2000 milliards dont moi qu on
en est très loin
deuxièmement à travers toute une série
d'astuces comptable sur les 750
milliards on sait très bien qu'il n'y
aura que 500 milliards d'argent frais et
donc qu'est ce qu'on se disait on se dit
que de ce point de vue là le plan de
l'union européenne
il est très présente deux sens de ce
qu'il faudrait faire
si nous voulions réellement rattraper ou
moins stabilisé notre situation par
rapport au pays d'aix
alors on se demande jacques où sont les
bonnes nouvelles alors y'a quand même
des bonnes nouvelles il faut lire les
bonnes nouvelles
elles portent plutôt sur le passé oui
c'est vrai la crise 2020 a été moins
grave que ce que l'on pouvait craindre
et je répète avec un moins vite moins
8,3 pour cent même si c'est un chiffre
assez terrible en lui-même al malgré
tout c'est mieux que ce que l'on pouvait
craindre encore au mois de novembre au
mois de décembre
c'est à dire des chiffres d'un mois 10
mois 11 voire -12%
donc oui il y a une bonne nouvelle en ce
qui concerne le choc de 2020 mais quand
on regarde ce qui va se passer en 2021
et en 2022 en particulier avec la fin
progressive des aides qui vont d'une
certaine manière révéler les dégâts qui
ont été faits dans l'économie bien quand
on se tourne vers le futur eh bien on
voit là que la situation est extrêmement
préoccupante que l'union européenne est
en train de décrocher dans la
compétition mondiale rapport aux pays de
l'asie émergente et que nous en france
nous sommes en particulier tirée vers le
bas par cette situation de l'union
européenne alors que l'allemagne
s'il faut parler d'elle justement eh
bien elle est d'ores et déjà prête à ne
pas respecter toute une série de règles
de l'union européenne
elle est prête déjà à lancer ses propres
plans sans trop se soucier de ce qui
sera fait en europe et donc on peut
quand même un moment donné se poser la
question est ce qu'il ne serait pas tant
que
la france élabore une politique
économique réellement nationale si elle
veut survivre dans les prochaines années
et merci jacques beaucoup de questions
merci pour cet éclairage édifiant à tous
points de vue et des semaines prochaines
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans
quelques instants avec pierre qui
s'habillent hivernaux pour un point
complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vie des idées
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient des lignes ans
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande île interview
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais